a key state
a key clinic in fact the only clinic
that is still operating uh in
mississippi it's called the pink house
that's the nickname uh given to it the
jackson women's health organization and
in the whole state this is the only one
still in operation and because of the
ruling yesterday many of the states
around mississippi have already enacted
their trigger laws so clinics in those
states are no longer operating at all
which makes this not only the the only
one that's still operating in the state
but within possibly a thousand miles
around and that is i think one of the
key concerns of people
across the country the the ability for
people to get abortions now they will
have to travel very long distances and
of course uh it is often the poorest who
are um who will will struggle the most
with that i want to take you up here
we've got to be a bit careful because
there are some very unpleasant posters
that the anti-abortion uh lobby have put
in place but we'll walk up here as
quickly as we can because i want to show
you
what happens um here this is a side road
that leads up to the car park of the
the abortion clinic and every day and
this has been happening for months and
months and months the anti-abortion
movement uh they come here and they
shout their loud hailers as you can hear
uh to
patients who are turning up here to have
abortions
it's it it does appear to be incredibly
intimidating we've seen that over the
course of this morning
people arriving
for appointments because although the
supreme court ban hasn't has come into
effect the governor here has not yet
signed it
and so there is a 10-day period during
which this clinic can still operate but
you can see uh here some of the um the
anti-abortion uh people on the gate and
and then in their um in their colorful
uh vests uh these are what are known as
clinic escorts people
who are trying to
comfort those who have made the choice
such difficult choices uh to come here
it's quite loud we'll move back a little
bit further but you can see um
car park through which um
patients come in and they have been
coming in this morning they continue to
come in we might be able to get a quick
word with one of the people um who is
here who was shouting his loud hailer
can we have a quick word with you uh um
uh brian is that all right just just
tell just very quick just i gotta help
her just tell me why why you're here
what you're doing because they're
murdering babies inside this uh pink
pink house right here the law has come
into effect now you've got you've got a
lot
in fact
people need to be prosecuted justice
needs to be upheld now
did you not think what you're doing is
is
just just more than a little bit
intimidating and making the lives for
people who are making very difficult
choices that much harder because hell is
going to be hot and forever
and we we're here because we we love
these people we love these women we want
these people uh women to repent uh we
want them to be saved and we want these
babies the bible says to stand for those
who cannot speak and stand for
themselves but but you are you were
shouting i was watching you this morning
you're shouting
listening
you don't think it's it's intimidating
and making a choice that these women are
having to make that much harder no no
that's why they put jesus on the cross
because he
preached the truth uh he even rebuked
his disciples when he said
he said they said we want to you need to
heal you don't paraphrase but you need
to heal
in this town he said no i gotta i gotta
go to the next town and preach
to repent of your evils of your will
lift thy voice and spare night
it's god's ordained method of saving
people and you repent at night
over the course of today we'll try and
speak to some people on the other side
of this argument one thing that struck
me when i arrived here last night i i
got in a taxi the taxi driver said to me
welcome to jackson mississippi where it
appears to be 1970 again i think that
sums it up for a lot of people here